meanwhile the stimulus fight continues
on capitol hill david spunt with the
latest live in washington david
hi eliza good afternoon to you it's not
just the stimulus fight for those
coveted relief checks
it's also whether or not senators will
vote to override the president's veto
of the national defense authorization
act that's the mechanism the annual bill
that funds the military let me explain
how those two
are tied together well first of all
senator bernie sanders the
independent senator from vermont has
said that he wants to stall the vote on
overriding the president's veto of the
ndaa
until the senate meeting senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
takes up a stand-alone vote on those two
thousand dollar
coveted relief checks direct payments to
the american people this is the same
bill
passed by the house on monday
give us a vote what is the problem
what is the problem with having the
american people see how their senators
vote
on this issue of such enormous
importance alecia five republican
senators are in favor of a standalone
vote
on the two thousand dollar direct
payments senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell not one of them he says he'll
only consider the two thousand dollar
direct payment proposal
if democrats agree to some things on the
president's wish list this includes a
bipartisan study looking at the
integrity of the 2020 presidential
election
mcconnell also wants democrats to repeal
section 230 of the communications
decency act
which protects big tech companies that
censor speech online
president trump has said for years that
companies like twitter and facebook
unfairly censor republican perspectives
socialism for rich people that's what
speaker pelosi and senator sanders
have sketched out a terrible way to help
those
who need it and experts across the
political spectrum agree
senate minority leader chuck schumer
said listen we will vote on the 2 30
repeal
we'll also vote on a bipartisan
commission looking at the integrity of
the election
let's do those separately not pair them
together with these two thousand dollar
direct payment relief checks
things are at a standstill right now and
the clock is ticking because guess what
the new senate is sworn in on sunday
alicia
that's right david spunton washington
thanks david